o
[Música]
tenía apenas 12 años cuando anunciaron
la conclusión del primer borrador del
genoma humano
el primer borrador del genoma humano se
anunció el 26 de julio del 2000 bill
clinton junto con francisco nin secret
member anunciaron que habían descifrado
en lenguaje de dios
si así es que dicha tenerte aquí pero
este día marcó mi vida y les voy a
explicar por qué con la conclusión del
primer borrador del genoma humano se
creía que se iban a encontrar la causa
genética de todas las enfermedades y de
esta forma desarrollar terapias
novedosas en este momento me quise unir
a ese grupo de científicos que querían
descubrir cuál era la causa genética de
las enfermedades y desde entonces he
dedicado mis últimos 14 años a tratar de
entender enfermedades raras primero como
genetista en la investigación después en
la clínica como médico y actualmente en
la industria está tratando de llevar
innovación para los pacientes sin
importar el camino que he seguido el
interactuar con los pacientes me ha
llevado a darme cuenta que para
realmente impactar sus vidas necesitamos
volver hacia adentro necesitamos volver
a lo más básico de los seres humanos y
por eso es que hoy vengo a explicarles
cómo considero que se debería innovar en
salud y para eso tenemos que
contextualizar nos la pandemia la
pandemia nos ha venido al vélez
lo que ya sabemos los sistemas de salud
se encuentran sobrecargados el personal
de salud está cansado de hecho en
recientemente una investigación
realizada en eeuu estimó que cerca de la
mitad de los profesionales en salud
muestran algún grado de depresión
ansiedad o sobrecarga de trabajo y es
que lo que ocurre es que cuando uno
trabaja en situaciones así tan adversas
lo hace más por un sentido de deber que
por una conexión real con los pacientes
recuerdo hace unos meses cuando estaba
en el hospital de mis pacientes con cody
en un turno de ocho horas falleció la
mitad y es que al comprometer esta
conexión con los pacientes estamos
impactando también cómo evoluciona su
enfermedad
por eso es que actualmente se sabe que
el poder mostrar empatía con los
pacientes impactan realmente su
evolución de hecho yo dije al pen
yo si saltan experta mundial en el
patria clínica
así es yo doy define la empatía clínica
como esa genuina curiosidad por escuchar
la historia del otro y dejar que nos
llegue a lo más profundo se sabe hoy en
día que el mostrar empatía afecta todas
las etapas del viaje de la enfermedad de
un paciente los pacientes que saben que
el médico le interesa que se preocupa
pueden revelar datos en la historia
clínica que hacen que se llegue un
diagnóstico temprano la principal causa
por la cual un paciente sale de un
consultorio y decide no apegarse al
tratamiento descartar el medicamento que
se le dio es no haber logrado conectar
con el médico y también el hecho de
poder manejar mejor las malas noticias
los diagnósticos difíciles el pronóstico
reservado tiene mucho que ver con esa
conexión que se forma con el médico
de esta forma es que debemos
preguntarnos qué es lo que nos motiva a
innovar en salud y es esa motivación
esta esa motivación alineada con
realmente lo que el paciente necesita y
aquí voy a referirme a la primera vez
que fui investigadora principal
estábamos tratando de descifrar cuál era
la causa genética de una familia en
pérez zeledón se trataba de una familia
numerosa con muchas necesidades y una
enfermedad que realmente les impedía
funcionar en su vida diaria en este caso
pues contábamos con la tecnología más
novedosa podía viajar a alemania e
investigar 25.000 genes de esa familia y
tratar de llegar a la causa para mi
sorpresa así como encontrar una aguja en
un pajar logré identificar qué era lo
que estaba sucediendo y con mucha
emoción me devolvía a costa rica-
explicarle a la familia cuál era la
mutación que causaba que una de sus
mitocondrias durante el neurodesarrollo
no funcionara adecuadamente y por ende
era que estaban enfermos para mi
sorpresa de la familia no estaba tan
emocionada con la noticia ni estaba
impactando realmente sus vidas fue
entonces que me di cuenta que a veces
queremos innovar queremos utilizar
tecnología novedosa para subsanar
diferentes etapas del recorrido de la
enfermedad de un paciente pero rara vez
estamos alineados con lo que ver de
verdad necesitan
y es entonces aquí donde me pregunto
será que un robot como pepper que además
de manejar información entretener pueda
lograr conexiones reales con los
pacientes será que un robot como pepper
nos poder recordar a nosotros cómo
volver a nuestras raíces de ser más
humanos y entonces a eso venimos con la
inteligencia artificial como un medio
para innovar en salud ya se utiliza la
inteligencia artificial con muchísimas
aplicaciones
sabemos hoy en día que por medio
inteligencia artificial podemos hilar
más fino en las imágenes médicas más
fino que cualquier ojo humano con
algoritmos de inteligencia artificial
podemos responder preguntas a partir de
una gran complejidad de información
mucho más rápido que el cerebro humano y
con inteligencia artificial también
podemos descifrar nuevos blancos
terapéuticos a través del modelaje por
medio de algoritmos pero qué distinto
sería desarrollar estos algoritmos desde
una visión un poco más humana un poco
más buscando conectar con los pacientes
pero bueno en todo esto
vamos a
quienes pp
soy un robot humanoide vamos socializar
y ayudar y que humanoide soy un robot
que está diseñado para socializar
reconozco campos visuales y pueda
sintonizar emociones a partir del
reconocimiento facial y palabras
el otro día andaba corriendo y me caí y
me dolió mucho tuve que parar del dolor
me entristece escuchar eso como que
puedo ayudar
no se sabe es bailar
quizás podrías bailar
claro
[Música]
[Risas]
gracias de que muchos años han pasado
desde que soñé con aplicar el
conocimiento científico y tecnológico
para impactar la vida de los pacientes
hoy sé que para realmente lograrlo
necesitamos llegar a lo más profundo de
nuestras raíces la medicina debe
personalizarse y al hacer esto vamos a
lograr encontrar muchas de las
respuestas que andamos buscando sea
peppers o cualquier otra innovación
tenemos que volver hacia lo más básico
de nosotros mismos muchas gracias por
acompañarnos hoy pp
qué gusto
toca el puño pepper en tiempos de 19 es
mejor chocar el codo pero como ésta es
vacunada y somos burbuja mejor un abrazo
si eres
escucho
gracias
con usted
[Música]